good evening my name is Michael Anton I
am a lecturer and research fellow here
at the Kirby Center which means that I
have teaching duties among other things
I taught a class Monday I taught a class
last night some of my students are even
here tonight and they shall withhold
further comment until the evening is
over as to the quality of instruction we
have students that many of you are
familiar with the college's program in
Washington but for those of you who
aren't just reiterate say four-year
liberal arts college in Michigan but
every semester a small number usually
around 20 take a semester and come here
as part of their college experience they
work an internship somewhere in
Washington that could be on the hill it
could be in a think tank can be in an
executive branch agency a non-profit and
then they take all their classes at
night so imagine I have a little
sympathy if you work 9:00 to 5:00 and
you got to drag yourself in here and
listen to me for three hours starting at
six o'clock it's it's hard on them but
they do very good work they work hard
and they're an impressive Bunch and you
be able to meet some of them tonight and
in fact one of them will be introducing
our speaker I was sort of asked to say
something about the topic of our speaker
I think because I served on the National
Security Council for a time and it's
presumed that I know something about
this unfortunately I don't really but I
do have one very small story I was a
speechwriter for a time on the National
Security Council back in the Bush
administration and I was the foreign
policy speech writer for the President
and the president gave a he had a sort
of a policy interagency working group
that was to determine the new space
policy for the United States and it went
on for many many months and it toward
the end they said well he's the
president's gonna roll out the Speights
speech and you got assigned I got
assigned the space speech so I got to go
to the final I don't know five or so
weeks of meetings to figure this out and
I remember asking when I was assigned
the speech my boss I said you know I'm
supposed to be the foreign policy guy
but lately you've been given me
immigration you've been giving me the
Patriot Act speeches you've just been
sort of piling it on and this is getting
difficult I mean what does this have to
do with my special duties and my boss
said well you know
spaces foreign so IRA I wrote the space
speech now my mother loved that speech
she was very impressed by it she watched
on television and called me later to
tell me how great it was it was not a
hit at the time this would have been I
think around January of 2004 and it was
widely ridiculed this is when the
President Bush announced that we would
go back to the moon we would eventually
move on to Mars and things like that and
people thought it was an election year
ploy and it wasn't a hit and it was a
famously the subject of a comedy skit on
a show I can't quote because this is a
family college but it's on YouTube and
was widely ridiculed and I think that's
the way it's most remembered today but
fast-forward a little bit so I was
working in a job in Manhattan and I got
invited the last minute to go out to a
small dinner and I show up and it's I
one friend of mine a bunch of people I
don't know and one person whom I didn't
know but I recognized it was Neil
deGrasse Tyson of all people right the
famous TV astronomer and astrophysicist
I don't know how it came up I don't
think I volunteered he somehow dragged
out of me that yeah I wrote the space
speech and I thought here it comes right
he's just gonna beat the heck out of me
actually was very nice about it he said
that he had consulted on the policy and
he had you know he thought the policy
was actually pretty sound with one or
two reservations and he remembered the
speech and he gave me a critique of it
right there he said these are the three
things you really screwed up but as for
the rest of it it was pretty good well
it could be worse all right now the
actual introduction of our speaker will
come from as I said a student one of the
we call them the the whip students which
stands for Washington Hillsdale
internship program her name is Riley
Arling house she is a junior at the
college where she's studying politics
and Spanish she's originally from
Missouri City Texas and I'll have you
know she's also the daughter of an air
force officer herself she is currently
interning at the Heritage Foundation
during her semester here please welcome
me in joining Riley to introduce our
speaker
[Applause]
good evening thank you for coming our
speaker tonight is Stephen L wast Steve
quest is a retired Air Force general and
former commander of the air Education
and Training Command at Joint Base San
antonio-randolph a graduate of the
United States Air Force Academy with a
degree in astronautical engineering he
holds a master's degree in public policy
from Harvard's Kennedy School of
Government he is a past president of the
Air Force's air university in Montgomery
Alabama and a former fighter pilot with
extensive combat and command experience
he is the author of the study fast space
leveraging ultra low-cost space access
for 21st century challenges and tonight
he will be speaking on the urgent need
for a u.s. space force please join me in
welcoming Steve quest
so Riley is an example of our future and
that's really what we're gonna be
talking about but history does repeat
itself so Michael I have your speech and
that's the one I'm going to give tonight
you you should probably recognize it a
bit but Riley thank you and you truly
are the future and that's why this is
such a happy conversation but it's also
one reason why it's such an important
conversation because life has always
been a competition ultimately a
competition of values and everything
else is wrapped around that but when we
ask this question about do we need a
space force
I'd like to unpack that a little bit
because it's important to first start
with why why do we need a space force
and once we understand why we need a
space force then we can talk about well
when do we need it and what should it do
critical elements of this central
question we're going to explore this
evening and I'm looking forward to your
questions
but one of the most important points of
thinking is first understanding what's
going on around you what's happening
what is the context here why is this
important
and as a historian reflecting on the
fact that throughout the history of
mankind at least everything we can read
and understand technology has always
changed world power whether it was the
caveman that figured out how to harness
the power of fire to keep his or her
tribe warm and survive the cold winters
and cook the food so they didn't die
from bacteria and other things they had
a competitive advantage and their DNA
survived their values survived to the
invention of the airplane the nuclear
weapon you take a look at any technology
that has been optimized by a certain
tribe civilization it can become a tool
of national power that changes world
power space is gonna change world power
because of the power of space and what
it can do we're gonna explore that a
little bit
night but it's also a story of human
nature and culture as a missionary kid
growing up in a tribal African area I
can tell you that world paradigms clash
and they they can't wrap a civilization
into a certain world paradigm and this
this human nature will not only embrace
something that helps them but it also
will reject anything new and this idea
of a space force is very new and is
experiencing the same but this is not
new in time a small island nation like
England could dominate the world economy
and become the most powerful military
economic and political force on planet
Earth as a small island nation because
they optimize the development of
deep-sea navigation and sail and ships
in the Navy but the story of rejecting
new and holding and clinging to the
paradigms of the past is why no
civilization has ever lasted forever and
values are trumped by other values when
another civilization figures out a way
of finding a competitive advantage and
in England probably the most famous
story is world war 1 in 1914 the English
were hungry to go to war with Germany
because they were certain that their
superior tactics and the Napoleonic
method of warfare that they had they had
refined to a perfect art that had
dominated the globe would dominate once
again and even though there were
historians and technologists and
strategists that pointed out the machine
gun and the development of poison gas
the leadership said we don't have time
for that the courage the nobility and
the aggressiveness of our fighters will
overcome our single rifles will just
overwhelm that machine-gun nest and
we'll just hold our breath and run
through the gas and fight on the other
side and after England lost in a
tired generation of Englishmen they
turned to their most respected intellect
dr. Fischer and asked the question why
did we lose an entire generation and he
said you didn't lose because you had
inferior technology you're a technology
you had the best technology on planet
Earth it wasn't your tactics your
tactics were perfect you lost an entire
generation because of a lack of vision
and strategy sunsuit in the art of war
talks about this it's not about the
technology it's about the strategy and
so here we sit today back in that day
there's historians and the technologists
brought to the leadership of England
this council that they needed to invest
in the machine gun and gas or at least
find ways of fighting through those
because those would change the character
of war and they ignored it saying we've
got time we've been the best so we will
be the best projecting the past into the
future we do the same today and this
community in America brought the
technologies that are emerging and the
strategies that are emerging
internationally and domestically to this
administration and this administration
said build a space force but the reason
space is so powerful is not that it's
just has a military application like a
machine gun it's because it will
transform the four major engines of
economic growth that have been
consistent throughout mankind
transportation information manufacturing
and probably most important the ability
to deliver that transportation and
information with energy energy the
seedcorn of all development all growth
all survival survival energy so energy
transportation information
Manufacturing these are the things that
change humanity that will change world
power and they are descending upon us in
ways that are very unique the technology
is on the engineering benches today but
most Americans and most in Congress have
not had time to really look deeply and
what's going on here but I've had the
benefit of 33 years of studying and
becoming friends with these engineers
and these scientists this technology can
be built today with technology that is
not developmental to deliver any human
being from any place on planet Earth to
any other place in less than an hour to
deliver Wi-Fi from space where you never
need a cell tower to connect to deliver
energy from space where you never have
to plug your phone in and a trickle
charges and you can use that energy over
time it can be applied to cars to houses
the technology of Edison and Tesla that
we live with in our energy environment
our paradigm today is expensive it's
dangerous and it's wasteful plugging
into the wall but yet that's out what we
all do because we are used to paradigms
the power of space will change world
power forever and it doesn't have to be
a big country to do it it can be a small
island country let's say New Zealand
because the technology if optimized can
change world power and there's nothing
you can do if you don't have that power
the nature of power you either have it
and your values rule or you do not have
it and you must submit we see that play
out again and again in history and it's
playing out now but we get trapped here
in America for example three times in
the last hundred years we have failed to
optimize the technologies that were
coming about to our own peril in 1920
the country turned to General Pershing
and General MacArthur that's the father
MacArthur the to Medal of Honor
recipients father and son in 1920 they
asked them the question
the airplane be developed independently
should the tank and mechanization be
developed independently and they said
absolutely not and they dictated that
the airplane and the tank
must be developed by the infantry
because the infantry is the main event
the Signal Corps is the main event and
that fatal decision by the most
respected and heralded heroes of the age
cost thousands of lives in world war ii
because the development of the airplane
and the tank were insufficient for the
competition and at that time it was
Germany we lost more Airmen in the
European theater than all of the Marines
in world war ii and the number of young
men we intentionally had to slaughter in
the sherman tank which its shell would
bounce off the Panzer in the tiger tank
we had to literally and knowingly
sacrifice an entire frontal attack to be
eviscerated by the German tank lines to
get enough Sherman's around the back
which at close range from behind was the
only way to kill a Panzer Corps tiger
with a Sherman tank and that's because
the people developing the tank and the
airplane every extra dollar was spent on
the infantry and a better gun because
that was the main event the tank was not
meant as a main event it was meant to
protect the infantry the airplane was
not the main event it was to spot troops
for the Signal Corps it was not intended
by anybody the biggest trap of culture
is mindset and we get trapped in a
mindset like electricity that it has to
be that way our children will be
plugging into a wall when the technology
does not need to be that way but here's
why space is so much more powerful and
why this question of a space force is
also important it's because we have
competition today if the development of
space to do these things that I just
described to you transform the transfer
transfer transportation economy to be
able to deliver anybody anywhere on
planet earth and let
in our transform the energy market where
everybody can trickle charge their
batteries and capacitors to power
anything on planet Earth from anywhere
without any power lines any power plants
trance transform information where you
can get information about what's going
around you and you don't need to be near
a city or near a cell tower because
you're delivering it from a networking
space they can deliver it to every human
being and then we can manufacture things
in space using the vacuum and zero-g to
not only do research medically but to
build facilities and structures in ways
we could have never done before and
deliver them as light as a feather
anywhere on planet Earth for pennies on
the dollar of transportation costs in a
linear sea land and air friction
environment and whenever humanity has a
new marketplace like this if there is
not some guardian force that brings
predictability to that economic
marketplace violence ensues pirates
thieves and thugs steal what good men
and women build and it's just a part of
human nature and that will not change so
as we look to these new markets and we
see Elon Musk building a starship that
will be able to launch from anywhere and
go anywhere in less than an hour with
massive volume and weight and he throws
up 12,000 satellites that would bring
you Wi-Fi from space where you will
laugh at the your descendants or your
your fathers and mothers it had to rely
on cell towers or see the little circle
of death waiting for signal they will
laugh and scoff at that they will laugh
and scoff that you had to put fuel into
your tank in your car or plug into a
wall because your phone was running out
of juice in the airports the lines
waiting for the outlet are no more we
get trapped in these paradigms but yet
just like Germany was competition for
the airplane the tank and the nuclear
weapon that we eventually won but at
great cost China is our competition
Russia is our competition they see the
power of the economy of space in these
four sectors and they are rushing to
that future and there is no guardian
force in America
but there is in China China has already
built the organization and has the
strategy and the doctrine the technology
and the builders for their guardian
Force of space they are building a navy
in space with the equivalent of
battleships and destroyers that will be
able to maneuver and kill and
communicate with dominance and we are
not now this analogy might help clarify
the picture going back to my original
comment of what's really going on here
the competition is not about making
better satellites or even having a
constellation of satellites when you see
China on the far side of the Moon
mapping today the minerals and the
resources so that they can eventually
have infrastructure to build and 3d
print and have a manufacturing industry
in space what you are watching is the
equivalent of us sitting here on our
continental United States let's say
we're in Miami and we're looking out
over the wide open ocean that ocean is
deep space the orbit around the earth is
the shoreline where the waves are
crashing the deep water is space and
there is a continent out there three
times the size of Africa that's the moon
and nobody lives there it's only three
days away it has massive amounts of
everything that Mother Earth has to
include water on the South Pole in the
craters greater than the Great Lakes as
far as volume and China is racing with
ships on that option open ocean to that
great open desolate place that can be
turned into resources and blessing for a
marketplace and they're doing it not
just to get the resources but to tap
into the trillion-dollar markets on
planet Earth
imagine what you could do if you could
sell technology to somebody from China
and deliver Wi-Fi and once you've built
the infrastructure in space you can
deliver it for pennies electricity where
your satellite dish doesn't just get
DirecTV now it gets energy it supplies
your Chinese batteries and capacitors as
they're building to get radio waves from
space that give you that energy over
time they will tap into those trillion
dollar markets as they have in the past
as we have in the past and fund their
ecosystem their economy their
marketplace in cislunar space which is
basically the distance between the earth
and the moon and beyond and we as an
American society we are sitting on Miami
Beach sipping our pina colada
looking out at the waves and as we are
watching China build this Navy with
battleships and destroyers going out
into the open oceans and off to this
continent three times the size of Africa
we are building buoys and lighthouses
which are the satellites they can see
and hear what's going on but can't do a
darn thing about that Rover on the back
side of the moon the far side of the
moon but if we were to try to go there
they could shoot us down and speed
matters speed matters because whoever
gets to the new market sets the values
for that market and we could either have
the market with the values of our
constitution where every human being is
created equal and loved equally by God
and their parents and their brothers and
sisters and that respect is manifested
in the rights of an individual to vote
to own land to bear arms all the things
the Constitution gives us or we can have
the values that we see manifest in China
Hong Kong the Weir's you pick your
example of subordination and crushing
religion
and human rights and human dignity and
human liberty but America is such a
good-hearted country we oftentimes are
deceived by the nature of China's
strategy their strategy is not to make
better satellites their strategy is to
build an economy before we do because if
you get there first they will be able to
with a constellation in space see and
kill anything that flies above the trees
the blood and treasure required to get
back to that high ground if we are not
there first will pale in comparison to
world war two and world war one in ways
that only those that study this
technology and its power can no because
China has met for thirty years they have
met every single milestone of their
space program and in the next ten years
they will have solar and nuclear power
generation space stations on orbit they
broadcast that they will be used for
peaceful purposes that those radio waves
will bring energy to anybody on planet
earth without the need for power lines
or power plants but in a millisecond
that dominance of the electromagnetic
spectrum can be directed energy that
could paralyze any part of our power
grid and freeze any military might
America builds on the spot every carrier
battle fleet is a cork in the water
every fleet of Fighters is dead on the
ramp can't even turn a wheel because of
our vulnerability China has openly
stated they are weaponizing everything
Western civilization was built on energy
and information and 5g is a perfect
example if you don't think they will act
in a way that steals our ideas and our
technology duplicate sit and then
dominates the marketplace take a look at
5g nobody 20 years ago would have ever
believed that America would not have an
answer to 5g when China rolled it out
why didn't we have it well it's pretty
easy
China invited
companies like loosen technology
motorola Nortel into china with a nice
package of benefits at the cost of
proprietary information intellectual
property and they built huawei out of
the bankrupt carcasses of those three
companies they stole the technology they
duplicated it and then they dominated
the marketplace in an unfair way unfair
perfect example Vietnam in 2006 they
were bidding for companies to come build
their telecommunication infrastructure
and so all these companies that were
world class global leaders in
telecommunications put out their bids
competitive bids Huawei's bid as a young
company being grown by the Communist
Party $0 they built it for free how do
you compete with that
the same thing is happening with the
space industry right now if you're a a
German that wants a satellite China will
give it to you for free if you buy their
satellite and they'll give you the
launch for ninety percent discount
far below what the market can bear
because they can funnel their political
focus their military focus and their
financial focus into a vision and a plan
that does not suffer from the blessing
of our republic where parties come and
go programs get crushed they come back
and you can't plan one year to the other
or some years you can't plan it all with
a continuing resolution or you can't do
anything new and you don't have any
money to do it this is the difference in
strategy a strategy of speed to get to
this new continent of wealth called the
moon and asteroids and a cislunar
economy to bring power to whatever
country dominates that economy it's like
America is a race car that has been
winning races for 70 years since World
War two we're going 90 miles an hour and
we've done it that way since World War
two it's our entire minds
our dad Tyrell lives the same way China
is in a car right behind us the car
isn't as good but it's going 120 miles
an hour we can say today we are dominant
in space but the trend lines is what you
have to look at and they will pass us in
the next few years if we do not do
something and they will win this race
and then they will put roadblocks up to
space because once you get the ultimate
high ground that strategic high ground
it's curtains for anybody trying to get
to that high ground behind them because
they can apply power maneuver and
communication and infinitesimally lower
price points and ultimately everything
is economic if you can do something
cheaper than I can do it you will
eventually beat me and all national
security comes from economies so speed
is essential so we are building
brilliant satellites we are building
brilliant commands but we will be like
taking a glorified knife to a tank fight
or the perfect single action rifle to a
machine gun fight because the strategy
is not fighting China strategy and we
are stuck in our mindset over the last
70 years and what space has done so far
this is not a military race this is an
economic race and if you do not have a
guardian force to bring rule of law and
predictability no venture capitalist
will know how to make risk decisions no
company will be able to invest and those
that do will have their hardwork stolen
away because the rule of law is not
codified by a guardian of course the
good news is there are more societies on
planet earth that share our values is an
American society that will work with us
to do this but right now we're paralyzed
look at what's happening in our
government yes argument is good but we
are paralyzed this National Defense
Authorization Act is it is at risk and
even though
even though this president was able to
get a space force into the dialogue when
he first said it the bureaucracy howled
with resistance and all only after a
year and a half of hard work are they
now on board just an example of the
resistance to the status quo wanting the
status quo to stay what it is but it's
ironic because it reminds me of story in
1400 it is an example that there's
nothing new Under the Sun and history
may not repeat itself but it sure does
rhyme that old saying that is clever but
true in 1400 China had a two-party
system Ming Dynasty the party in power
saw this thing called a navy and said
that is powerful because that Navy fleet
will mean that the ocean is not a
barrier but rather a highway to new
marketplaces and they built the biggest
Navy on planet earth they would have
been the England of 1400 had they
finished the job but the bickering of
politics when the new party came into
power they burned every ship to the
ground in spite because the other
party's idea was the idea for a navy and
not theirs that began began a 600 year
journey to the century of humiliation
and I am here to tell you I read every
document that comes out of China I read
every speech by every senior policy
official and I will tell you they talk
about this story and that the Middle
Kingdom is back and America is in its
crosshairs and space is the Navy for the
21st century economy a networked economy
that will dominate any linear
terrestrial economy in the four engines
of growth and dominance that change
world power transportation information
energy and manufacturing and they are
building that infrastructure they are
unapologetic about it
and they plan on declaring victory as
the dominant world power and space at
the 100-year anniversary
20:49 and in the next 10 years their
energy in space with nuclear and solar
power that can be beamed to the earth
for good and for bad their ability to
control gateways a 5g using space
quantum artificial intelligence
supercomputing to be able to shape the
perception of the world and to tell any
story and to lie about America or
anybody else that is counter to their
purpose and you see how our independent
inter dependency as a world plays out
when China can lie about America to all
global markets and how that affects our
economy and our stock market ultimately
it is the manifestation of a long
patient plan to dominate information and
energy has weapons against the West so
China's Middle Kingdom can come back
this is why we need a space force this
is why it needs to be now because if we
fumble the football politically this
year it'll be two years before we get
another National Defense Authorization
Act that will give this the chance to
survive and that's two years of money in
the bank at compound interest for China
who's furiously swimming away to that
continent of Africa as we're sitting on
the beaches of Miami admiring the tide
and our buoys and lighthouses they can
see exactly what's going on on the
shoreline in our orbit why do we need a
space force because it's an economic
competition for the values of the future
when do we need it now what does it need
to do it doesn't have to have
warfighting capability it has to be able
to defend the economy of space a Coast
Guard a Merchant Marine for space
because the national security muscles
and capabilities will flow easily once
we tap in
the profits of those marketplaces just
like we have a strong Navy because we
have a strong shipbuilding industry and
a strong Merchant Marine and just
because we have a strong air force
because the aerospace industry is our
largest export as a nation this is what
long term strategy and economic power
look like and this is what we need and
the scientists engineers historians and
strategists of our age have brought this
to our government the government has
said do it and now Congress is asking
the question why do we need to spend
money on a space force it would be like
Teddy Roosevelt getting pushed back
saying why do we need a Panama Canal why
do we need an Eisenhower interstate
system it's for commerce the power of
the perpetuation of the American Dream
and the American values you are at a
pivotal point the American people don't
know this story Congress doesn't even
know this story adequately except for a
few and if we don't get this story out
your grandchildren children will
probably be speaking Chinese that's not
a bad language because the Chinese
people are beautiful people but their
communist party will murder the future
generations of free loving people
Liberty can be snuffed out if we are not
mindful of the power of technology and
the trap of a mindset that clings to the
status quo
instead of allowing our engineers and
our inventors and our marketplaces build
a new future with new paradigms to
dominate the market places of the 21st
century thank you for your time and for
listening and I look forward to your
questions
[Applause]
see that speech you wrote was awesome
Michael my question is rhetorical which
is we've seen a lot of news lately about
career officers Foreign Service officers
so-called deep Staters in the National
Security Council I have my misgivings
about that but then I asked if we're
gonna have them we can't we have this
guy okay questions and there are
microphones roving around so please wait
until you were handed to Mike before you
for us audience can you hear the
question and people online sure pardon
me could you describe the nature of this
all gets the SAP level almost
immediately so but for everybody's
edification could you describe the our
offensive and defensive capabilities in
space versus those that are adversaries
currently have and what they will have
in the very near future
okay so everybody heard that question I
will tell you that whether you're an
army officer a naval officer an Air
Force officer a Coast Guard officer a
Marine officer it doesn't matter there's
one truth about a new domain if you want
to dominate it and you want to bring a
rule of law you have to be able to
maneuver more aggressively and a cheaper
price points than your competition you
have to be able to communicate more
ubiquitously and more resilient ly than
your competition and you have to be able
to bring power to bear whether that's
kinetic power informational power non
kinetic power you have to be able to
bring power to bear and you have to do
all those three things cheaper and
faster than your competition and you
have to be able to deny your competition
those three things
China is feverishly working on those
three components to be applied outside
of the gravity well that's beyond the
orbits into the moon and the Sisler nur
space using the Sun as their source of
energy that is perpetual and can be
beamed to any place in that ecosystem
they are literally building the coal
stations equivalent to the ones we built
in the Pacific when Teddy Roosevelt
built the Great White Fleet with iron
ships instead of wooden ships
in fact that story is another one the
wooden shipbuilders and the sail up sail
builders did not want to let go of the
wooden ship it was better than these
stinky old iron ships that was another
journey of a new paradigm that had to
crush an old paradigm and it was hard
long so I will tell you this everything
I've said is in the open press but much
of it and has to be translated from
Mandarin and that's another problem our
journalists and our American public has
an understanding what's going on but I
will tell you this 33 years of studying
technology the Chinese culture history
human nature China is feverishly
developing capability to dominate those
three areas in cislunar space and we are
not we are perfecting orbital mechanics
the shore line work precision quality
brilliant capability and equipment but
irrelevant to China they can maneuver
outside the gravity well around the
backside of the moon and there's nothing
we can do if we are not dominant in that
geography as well so that's why the
space force is so urgent because China's
got a head start there that car right on
our bumper going 120 miles an hour it
won't be better than what we'll build
because we have an open market free
economy ideas flourish but China steals
them so fast duplicates them so rapidly
floods a market so insidiously that even
the brilliant idea like what Tesla did
with their battery that China stole and
duplicated even a brilliant idea like
that we're behind the power curve 5g we
have no answer because China took all
our stuff built it flooded the market
and now if you're a company that doesn't
have 5g you can't compete because speed
is life in the 21st century and we don't
have an answer Germany wants it we would
love as an American country to give them
some 5g with the values of America
behind it but they only have one option
and that's China
yeah I'll let you decide who goes right
there yeah sorry she is much
better-looking than you are it's all I
gotta say thank you so much for your
speech I'm also one of the whip students
here and my question is you've talked a
lot about the two competing paradigms
Heather's the old one and the new one
and the famous scientific philosopher
Thomas Kuhn often spoke about how these
paradigms are incommensurate to each
other meaning that if you're in one
paradigm you can't understand what
someone's saying from another paradigm
how do you propose that we bridge that
gap to bring people from the old way of
viewing things into the new way in a
manner that's effective and that helps
us spread our values around the world
that's a great question and this is
something that I'm so glad you asked
because history gives us all the answers
to this question and one of the reasons
why I was fortunate enough to see this
is because I grew up in a different
world paradigm I was raised in a tribe I
didn't have to go to school which
explains a lot by the way still can't
write or spill very well but I and then
coming to a different world paradigm at
a fragile young age allowed me to see
how devastating the communication gap
can be between paradigms and we as
civilizations build a paradigm like
energy let's say the electricity that we
have delivered and we squirrel away at
inventing and innovating within that
paradigm and nobody looks outside to say
hey is there a different economic curve
here we could jump to but there are
enough people in our society that know
how to jump to that curve Elon Musk Jeff
Bezos Richard Branson God rest his soul
Paul Allen okay
luckily they have the money to actually
do something but they were rebels they
were Mavericks they were ridiculed until
they proved it okay so this is this
played out with Franklin Delano
Roosevelt when we saw that Germany was
pursuing the bomb and we knew that if
they got that bomb first it was
intuitive that we had to be fast FDR did
not turn to the bureaucracy of the army
and say build me a bomb because he knew
the status quo and the bureaucratic
organizations never can jump out of
their paradigm
the pig does not slaughter itself okay
you have to get outsider so that's why
Congress and the executive branch have
always been the ones that have changed
the military not inside so what FDR did
is he found the right leader and that
was Oppenheimer he Eisenhower did the
same thing as the Soviet Union was
rearing its ugly head and the army was
suggesting putting a million soldiers
with bayonets affixed in the folded gap
of Germany Eisenhower said no because
one tactical nuke will kill all my sons
and daughters and I can't afford it and
he turned to two innovators general
Schriever and Admiral rickover and he
said build me a nuclear triad so we can
have a balance now mutual assured
destruction is no happy way of going
through life but it was a way of having
a bulwark against this devastating
technology the same is true today we
need a Manhattan type project in order
to develop this properly because the
price of entry to space is so high that
only billionaires that are willing to
pour their own money into it are making
any progress but they are pounded and
blocked at every turn
Elon Musk for example has to pay the Air
Force 13 million dollars every time he
launches from Vandenberg Air Force Base
for no good reason just risk aversion in
a bureaucracy and when everything goes
perfect he doesn't get that money back
they use it for their own coffers and
their own things but that's the cover
your butt kind of mentality that happens
in a bureaucracy that cannot jump
outside of the paradigm there's no other
way turn into the government or the
bureaucracy to do this will not work but
an executive branch or a Congress that's
willing to pick the right leader that
understands the technology the history
the culture the paradigm and picks the
right engineers and scientists they'll
build it because there's nothing more
powerful than the American free
enterprise that welcomes diversity of
thought and will try things and fail and
no Communist Party is going to shoot
them if they fail if they fail for the
right reasons they are promoted they
fail for the wrong reasons you coach
them
and if they fail three times you fire
Admiral for example general Schriever as
he was building the missile fields of
our nuclear triad the first 13 rockets
blew up okay
only Eisenhower was able to protect him
from the hounds of Congress and the air
force that hated them that wanted him
out that felt that his work was coming
at the cost of the manned bomber history
is playing out again did that answer
your question who's next
your mic is coming hi I'm Jacob rich
from Reason Foundation yes and I'm
curious so you said that China's already
started building destroyers and other
military vessels for space
I'm just curious should we steal their
intellectual property to catch up well I
will tell you that this is the insidious
nature of strategy versus equipment okay
so China is building nuclear thermal
power propulsion capabilities to be able
to maneuver in space we know how to do
that and we can do it better their stuff
is not good
now 5g is good the 5g technology is good
because it's our stuff but the stuff
they're building is not better than what
we can build it's not about equipment
it's not about stealing their ideas
because their ideas are inferior to ours
it's the fact that they're building an
entire method of being able to have a
blanket of power over America in space
they can bring directed energy to
paralyze our power grids paralyze our
cars paralyze our military disrupt our
markets they're doing it on a social
level with the Confucius centers and a
narrative the small space companies for
example I could bring in the CEOs of the
small space companies and here's what's
happening to them they'll be somebody
that come up to them and say I will give
you a billion dollars if you put me on
your board and when they follow the
money it was China they gave him the
money gave an American that money and
said here's a billion dollars for free
go and get on the boards of these
companies and your only price tag is to
bring me the intellectual property and
proprietary information and so it's hard
a company will come to me and say what
do I do
and I'll say do not take the money
because you will sell your soul this is
where the government needs to help the
government needs to help make sure
there's an even Plainfield economically
or all these fragile new space companies
will never build an industrial base
equivalent to the aerospace industry or
the shipbuilding industry that have made
our nation free and strong for the last
hundred years and it will die on the
crib the space force and everything we
need to do to protect this economy will
die in the crib and China will own the
information the gateways the
technologies that flood all the other
countries of the world even our friends
like Germany and England have 5g and are
getting more and more of it our nuclear
power plants have 5g technology in them
and those are all riddled with backdoors
and spyware they can see everything
we're doing as a nation we know it this
is like a slow growing vine around the
spinal cord of America insidiously and
slowly because that is the mindset of
the Chinese strategy it is not to fight
they don't want to fight they want to
dominate the economic prowess of America
over a hundred years
and we go out with a whimper sure
so you mentioned the fact that the
executive in the Congress effective
military to the same respect do you
think changing the public's mind will be
helpful as well that's great question
and yes there are two groups of people
that do not understand what's going on
the American people and Congress I mean
and again you know I retired in
September and I have been spending my in
every waking hour helping Congress
understand what's going on here because
it's essentially the same as China
ignoring the Navy and regretting it
600 years later when their civilization
rotted from within because of external
players that stole away their values or
England that lost an entire generation
of men before they realized what the
competition was really about it wasn't
about Napoleonic soldiers shoulder to
shoulder on a parade filled with courage
it was about the machine gun and gas and
it killed them all deep regret but they
went into it enthusiastic I mean read
the literature of the time 1914 they
couldn't wait to go die they just didn't
know they were gonna die they thought
courage would save them they
underestimated the power of technology
we're doing the same right now but the
enemy is not as aggressive China is
passive China is silent China is
insidious
China has a 100-year plan one step at a
time
a slow-growing vine that slowly
paralyzes the competition so the
American people need to know they do not
know help me get it to them Congress
doesn't fully know and the reason I know
that is not only because I've been
talking to them some do but they're
still asking this question why do we
need a space force there's a waste of
money we've got NASA that would be like
sending the wagon trains out west with
no cavalry
okay see I said something that it'd
inspire you inspired you to ask a
question cuz you popped up yeah oh thank
you for coming I want to talk about the
balance of power in the Asia Pacific I
think Japan should go nuclear
they won't maybe in five years maybe ten
years that that's gonna offset the
Chinese advancing that's what I think
okay well let me talk to that because
that I disagree fundamentally with that
premise and it's not that that wouldn't
necessarily have a short-term benefit of
deterrence but the power of space does
something really important here and and
and this is really wearing an end but
I'll just do a little slice of this and
then I'll end with a later part and that
is a vision the power of space can do
what Reagan was doing and the physics
just didn't quite close brilliant
pebbles was the program to put a space
base layer that could see and kill any
missile launched the moment we knew is
launched in a direction that was
nefarious to American values and it
could be shot down before it even left
the geographic boundaries of whichever
place it was launched you can build that
off the shelf today and we have not and
China is so Japan going nuclear know
what we could do if we as an American
Society decided to invest in the
infrastructure of space for information
for all Americans reliable energy
information that's protected by the way
because it's not the Internet you can
build gateways that design trust into it
where every American can have their data
without having to sacrifice their civil
liberties energy that can be provided to
anybody on planet Earth without strings
attached like they do with the Uighur
and Hong Kong and any individual where
they hold their parents hostage if they
don't behave properly or they don't get
to go to the right schools or then
get to buy the food that's good space
can make ICBMs intercontinental
ballistic missiles literally antiques of
past Wars and then I'll end with the
other vision but that's one vision you
can literally get you you can't get rid
of nuclear weapons because you can
always deliver them in a backpack or
some other means but you can deliver the
capability to dominate market places
economically and you can literally
design a new world order that does not
have so much violence built into our
deterrence model where if a civilization
is threatening our values we can deter
them without violence in ways they
cannot compete with so I'd rather not go
the route of arming more people with no
more nuclear weapons we don't have to go
down that paradigm that's getting
trapped in the paradigm of the past I
want to move to a new paradigm where
China can't follow and most other
countries on planet earth cannot follow
either but all of our friends will go
with us and the Japanese are part of
that I mean there's a very inquisitive
question right here and that's trying to
hear okay we'll get back go ahead have
we an idea the cost of this initiative
yeah so the condoms European phases but
right so cost is always the first
question and bureaucracy because right
now what has happened as our country has
turned to our military and said build a
space for us and I guarantee you it'll
be bureaucratic it'll be big it'll be
expensive and it won't get the job done
that's the nature of a bureaucracy and
the government now it well maybe you
succeed in 50 years but we don't have
that luxury because our pacing has to be
predicated on our competition not on the
fact that we have been unilaterally
dominant economically for the last 70
years and we could do anything at any
pace we wanted and we didn't have to
care because nobody was competing so
here we are sitting on the shores of
Miami Beach with our pina colada
okay and we are like a space force
yeah how much is it gonna cost I will
tell you you don't build the space force
out of the coffers of the taxpayers
money
we built an automobile industry because
it was so useful to people the
marketplace built it the computer
industry the aerospace industry space is
going to be so useful to all humanity
trillion-dollar markets in
telecommunication trillion-dollar
markets in transportation speed is life
speed is money how many people are
willing to get from here to Singapore in
39 minutes instead of 39 hours no not
quite that far so I am here to tell you
that if this is done right the strategy
is to build the space force with the
profits of the marketplaces that you
dominate and you've got partners in
civil society Elon Musk Jeff Bezos Elon
Musk is going to dominate transportation
and information with his starship and
his 13,000 satellites for Wi-Fi from
space we already have companies that are
going to have texting from space next
year in fact their test satellite is
already up and I don't need a cell tower
to text so this is the trick of free
markets you build it with the profits of
the marketplace if you design it right
that's why all national security is
foundationally economic hopefully
private industry absolutely those are
the titans of innovation
they aren't bogged down by a culture of
risk aversion that bakes in to our
government and our military and they're
willing to take risk and those are the
only ways of competing and winning in a
real race risk and the willingness to
fail all right this will be the last one
I'll let you I just you lady right here
- well I do - here there's a mic and if
it's not a good question I'll answer the
question I want to answer
my question is what can we do to spread
this information because I have this is
not new we get tidbits of this through
the news media but nothing to the extent
that you have explained it tonight this
is critical to the future of our country
amen
this is it yeah this is where an
educated electorate is so key to our
Constitution that our founding fathers
wrote about and do not underestimate the
power of a network okay
one node touching three other nodes that
touch three other nodes it's this the
sage old story of a young man who really
did something brilliant for the king and
the king said well I don't have a lot of
money but what can I do to repay you and
the man said just give me one grain of
rice on this chessboard on this first
square and on the second square give me
two and keep doubling it for every piece
of the chessboard now many of you
probably know this story by the time you
have gotten to the end of the chessboard
squares how much rice do you have okay
so the entire planet Earth six feet high
that's the power of a network and it's
interesting that we we end on a network
because there's another important point
about space so the answer your question
specifically is tell your friends and
start reading it is out there it's just
hard to find and it's out there but just
recently in this way because I couldn't
write about this in the airforce the
people do not want to scare the American
people and I I don't want to scare them
either but for God's sakes our future is
at stake here we are victims to a
strategy we don't even recognize and as
a person who grew up in a different
cultural paradigm they can see
clearly and has studied this for 33
years I am here to tell you it is
eminent and the more we can be in the
dark the happier China is because then
the coup de Gras is done and it is fate
of complete and there's nothing we can
do about it and now I believe that
America is so energetic intellectually
and so courageous that eventually we
will fight our way back
but the English haven't even fought
their way back from World War one so it
can happen it can the next hundred years
the values that will rule the next
hundred years will be defined by this
next ten years and who dominates space
so here's the vision though that this is
why I started by saying this is such a
happy story okay you might think oh my
god
you know doom and gloom no here is a
story every technology even though
people can use technology for evil every
technology has uplifted the human
condition over time if you if you if you
take a look at the human race there are
a higher percentage of human beings that
have energy water security food than
ever before on planet Earth ever now
there's more people so there's more
people in poverty than ever before but
the ratio is moving in a good direction
it's because there are more people that
love their children and respect other
people than there are evil people like
Stalin and Lenin and Mao that would kill
them for power and this constitution I
believe is such a unique and ordained
document that if we fumble the ball now
because we don't pay attention to
technology and how it can change world
power shame on us
but here's the vision the vision is with
a new paradigm that space could bring us
if we built this infrastructure if we
had the vision to build the Panama Canal
of our age the infrastructure of space
we can bring clean and abundant energy
afford
every person on planet earth with no
power lines no power plants required
Central Africa where I grew up that
tribe could have information and energy
right now we have machines that can
bring water out of the air with that
energy from space where you could just
give them a piece of technology and they
can have clean water with no pipes no
aquifers no rivers required you can
bring trusted information to any person
on planet Earth where they do not have
to live with a scourge of an internet
was designed to be open and free no
security yet we are trapped in that
paradigm spinning ourselves into
oblivion into bankruptcy trying to make
something secure that was never designed
to be secure we could bring secure
trusted data to every human being on
planet Earth underpinned by American
values and the American Constitution we
could bring medical healing because of
research facilities in space that
benefit from zero gravity and a vacuum
that we can never do in an in in the
terrestrial realm without great cost and
energy the server farms in America that
are growing exponentially that are
sucking energy beyond belief could be
put into space and no energy required
because it's freezing up there
and the ability to communicate and
compute the faster we can move to
independent operations in space the more
secure we will be the more differential
power we'll have as an economy and as a
civilization to defend against terrorism
and the despot of communism that are
rearing their ugly head and trying to
come after Western civilization and
attacking the two foundational
weaknesses we have built our entire
prosperity on energy and information and
both of them are at risk and both of
them are unaffordable to fix so don't
struggle we're struggling to get a
secure grid a resilient grid we're
struggling to get secure data and
resilient data stop struggling let our
inventors and our innovators design a
new paradigm to uplift the human
condition and have America underwrite it
and America will be the venn
beneficiaries to the
amount of trillions of dollars of profit
to perpetuate those business cases to
deliver every human being on planet
earth prosperity and the blessing that
we respect them no matter who they are
no matter what they believe as long as
they respect us that's the vision that's
the joy not the negative stuff the
negative stuff is only if good men and
women do nothing then the negative stuff
happens and we want we return to our
academics and say like they did to dr.
Fisher in England
why did we lose a generation of men a
lack of vision a lack of strategy not
equipment their equipment was brilliant
but it wasn't a machine gun or gas and
they didn't even think about it we're
too courageous for that we'll be just
fine
just like we have been for the last
hundred years and that's what you hear
today who's here we don't need a
separate space force because we want to
integrate it into the joint force and
the army and the terrestrial fight
that's our purpose not even thinking
beyond the orbits into cislunar space
and the trillion-dollar markets that
will come from that we are at a point in
civilization where for the first time in
human history we can reach to the
heavens a gift God has given us for our
resources our energy and our information
in a way that will never have to scar
the earth again for all those things we
need we need resources to feed our
families and shelter our people we need
the ability to defend those things we
need the sense of belonging that comes
with loving our families and our tribes
and we need to understand what's going
on around us those are the only four
things we need resources defending the
resources a sense of belonging and
understanding space can give us that but
the journey of a thousand miles to the
cost and the time people say this is 200
years too soon
it's too expensive a journey of a
thousand miles starts with the first
step
and we haven't even take the first step
and if we don't get a National Defense
Authorization Act we've been given we
will be giving our competition that has
taken tremendous leaps into this future
two years of compound interest in the
ahead of us that 120 mile an hour car on
our bumper will be two miles in front of
us and they'll put up those barriers
they'll throw out those tacks onto the
road so our tires deflate we may have a
better car but without good tires you
aren't going anywhere
that's what I'm talking about all right
thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]